et on ne pourra pas rester durablement
dans un système où l'enseignement
supérieur n'a aucun prix pour la quasi
totalité des étudiants ou un tiers des
étudiants sont considérés comme boursier
heo pourtant nous avons tant de
précarité étudiante et une difficulté à
financer un modèle qui est beaucoup plus
financé sur l'argent public que partout
dans le monde pour répondre à la
compétition internationale
nous devons regarder cette réalité en
face nous avons un problème
malgré tout cet investissement ces
améliorations
d'orientation et de choix en tout cas de
la première année universitaire et je
parle juste de présentation aux examens
c'est intolérable pour nous tous parce
que c'est un formidable gâchis c'est un
gâchis pour toutes celles et ceux qui
ont suivi prodiguer les cours pour ces
étudiants c'est un gâchis aussi parce
que ça veut dire qu'on a refusé d accès
à d'autres étudiants dont 7 et parfois
le premier choix autre exemple nous
sommes dans un pays et c'est une fierté
mais où un étudiant sur trois est
boursier a pu en bénéficier
et pourtant nous n'avons jamais vu
autant de précarité étudiante